[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me if you'd like to do
more to keep this channel afloat
consider donating through the PayPal
Link in the description or checking out
our patreon thanks guys so much
so if you haven't been introduced to the
work of Aleister Reynolds allow me to
introduce you the specific book that
we're going to be talking about today is
called House of sons
now Aleister Reynolds has a lot of
science fiction books some of them
connect to each other some of them don't
this one is mostly Standalone though
there might be a short story or two that
take place in the same universe now
there is a lot going on in this book a
lot of really interesting science
fiction Concepts so in this universe
Humanity has spread out to inhabit the
entire Milky Way galaxy now this is
about six million years in our future so
humans have changed a lot there are
Baseline humans who look more or less
like you or I and there are humans that
look very very different even humans
that are so different that they are
technically post-human there is also a
race of sentient machine people that
coexist with Humanity so mainly in this
book we follow gentian shatterlings the
concept of the shatterlings is very
interesting to me so in this universe
the lines are each made up of shatter
links shatterlings are both male and
female clones of a single individual the
lines are essentially the most powerful
groups in the entire galaxy lines unlike
most human groups don't really live on
planets they travel the Galaxy and they
meet up every circuit which is about two
hundred thousand years
shatterlings can live for millions of
years but they don't experience all of
that time due to the nature of Subspace
travel a lot of that time is spent in
hibernation they'll think nothing about
hibernating 50 60 years or even longer
waiting to get to their destination and
also it would be impossible for them to
experience that amount of time anyway
because their brains were too close to
Baseline human
Baseline humans couldn't comprehend deep
time it would make them go insane but
there were groups who could and that
leads me to what I really want to talk
about in this book which is the
vigilance and the curators
so before we get to the vigilance and
the curators one thing that you need to
know about this universe is that at some
point in time the Andromeda galaxy The
Milky Way's closest Celestial neighbor
vanished in its place was only darkness
and no one knew why
but there were many who speculated on
what possibly could have happened
in common with the vigilance I hold that
the absence is the result of organized
activity by alien sentience
intentionally or otherwise they have
caused something to happen to their
Galaxy as a sentient resident in a
similar spiral galaxy I naturally have
at least a passing curiosity concerning
the event in question
if the Andromeda priors did something
foolish then it is in our interest not
to repeat that mistake
a curious thing about this book is that
because of the nature of sub lights be
travel one of the most common forms of
currency in the galaxy is information
and that's why the main characters in
this story travel to meet with the
vigilance because a major question
that's on everybody's mind is what
happened to Andromeda they referred to
its disappearance simply as the absence
now the vigilance was extraordinarily
ancient they existed and what can kind
of be described as a Dyson Sphere except
not totally solid it was more like a
Dyson swarm a star surrounded by
countless spheres each one of them a
constructed world now the vigilance was
regulated by ancient humans known as the
curators
the curators had found a path to
immortality that was unlike any others
found in the Galaxy their path to
immortality required them to grow and
never stop because of this they were
enormous
I am not the oldest curator but I am
still growing all of us are in the dawn
of our kind we found a pathway to
biological immortality that depends on
continued growth there are other
Pathways but this one we settled upon
are there curators larger than you
absolutely you will not see them though
they inhabit the larger nodes with the
most important kernels most of them are
too large to leave now their heads would
fill this chamber many who came into
contact with the vigilance never
returned
some returned insane
any of them returned with a particular
impression that the vigilance valued
certain sets of data more than others
but this was only discernible when their
transactions of information were
examined over deep time the vigilance
possessed a particular interest in the
absence the vigilance had been watching
the Galaxy long before the time of its
existence they were at least expecting
something to occur I think you knew
exactly how you were going to end up
from the moment you started you were
going to become huge slow Giants and you
were never going to stop growing and
that's interesting to me because it
implies that the purpose of the
vigilance was set in stone long before
the absence happened it caught everyone
else unawares but unless I'm wrong you
were waiting for it the important thing
to mention about the absence is that
it's kind of a misnomer there is still
something there there are even some
Stars left over that were outside of the
event when it Formed now the mystery of
the absence is one of those great
science fiction mystery
and while reading this book I loved
watching the mystery unfold and I love
trying to figure it out so before I tell
you what the explanation for the mystery
is I'm gonna give you a spoiler warning
so if you don't want to know what the
answer to the mystery is you can click
off this video right now so the universe
has natural restrictions on space-time
and this particular Universe faster than
life speed is not possible the universe
prevents it from being so to avoid
problems in causality to avoid paradoxes
we've all heard of the going back in
time and killing your own grandfather
and therefore you never exist but you
never went back in time to kill your own
grandfather so it's a paradox a universe
breaking Paradox an ancient group had
attempted to create a wormhole shortcut
between the Milky Way galaxy and the
Andromeda galaxy but in doing so they
were essentially opening the universe up
to breaks in causality a warm hole is
essentially a time traveling machine
Stephen Baxter's zeely sequence comes to
mind now since they had an interest in
preserving causality they created the
absence the absence was essentially a
barrier permitting information flow one
way but not the other
but the twist is it wasn't just
Andromeda
the Milky Way galaxy because of the
super liminal information flow between
the galaxies had to be screened off from
the rest of the universe as well so from
the outside the Milky Way would also
appear as a dark emptiness in space but
that's not all
aren't the only ones there are other
galaxies other areas in space that have
been completely screened off by super
civilizations some of you might have
heard of the boatys Void the myth is
that it's a region in real life space
containing nothing No Light No Stars
nothing well of course in actuality
there isn't actually nothing it's just a
regional space that's not very populated
well in the house of sons this is just
another region that some super
civilization has sealed off to hide
their wormhole
so what I really love about this is not
only the mystery as it unfolds in the
book but just the exploration of cosmic
macro Engineering in this book because
that's something that I've always been
really interested in we as humans always
take our environment and change it to
fit us we build things we build huge
things and if we are doing that to the
Earth already and we continue to prosper
there's only an amount of time before we
do that on a cosmic scale another thing
about this book is that unlike a lot of
other science fiction faster than light
travel is not possible we still don't
know if faster than light travel is
possible in the real world that's
something that we might never have so
it's awesome to see science fiction
portray a universe that's still
Fantastical but doesn't use that
particular element that's often so
common in science fiction so if you want
to grab this book make sure to use my
Amazon affiliate Link in the description
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like for more Quinn's ideas
also consider donating to keep this
channel afloat by clicking the PayPal
dot me link or checking us out on
patreon thanks guys
[Music]
foreign